I think it's surreal it's just amazing
all hail the new reigning queen of
tick-tock it means the world to me
that's right
Charlie D'Amelio just surpassed two
Lauren gray to become the most followed
person on the platform the 15 year old
to join tick-tock last June has 41 point
4 million followers and Counting while
17-year old Lauren has 40 1.3 million I
think
it's surreal because it's weird that
people know my name and it's weird that
I get to do interviews and meet a lot of
new people that it's just amazing it's
there's so many opportunities that I'm
I've been given because of it et caught
up with Charlie in February and she
opened up about her fast rise to fame on
tick tock makes it so worth it because
no matter what anyone says I do what I
do for all these people that say I
inspire them or I'm the reason they got
into dance lesson it just makes
everything so worth it and it makes me
so happy that I can say like I'm helping
people in love little way I am like it
just it means the world to me and
earlier this month ET chatted with
Lauren who admitted she does struggle
with the desire to stay popular on
tik-tok on the inside there's always
that like oh my god like you have to
constantly keep up but at the same time
I've come to peace with the fact that
you know numbers don't matter and I've
always done it for fun so I started for
fun and I'm in it for the fun of it and
you know there's always gonna be the
next person but I feel like as long as
I'm still doing my thing like it doesn't
really matter there's room for everyone
have a sandwich
classic [ __ ] Reggie and Lauren
wasn't wrong
both Lauren and Charlie are killing it
Lauren made a cameo in Taylor Swift's
music video for the man and Charlie so
it was really a dream come true well she
got to meet her idol at the Super Bowl
in Miami a couple years ago I decided
that my dream is to dance with JLo and
she was on top of my vision board I've
talked about her and almost every
interview I've done whenever they ask
what my biggest dreams are when I first
met her and I got to shake her hand and
I was just blank face I didn't know what
to say and then it kind of set in and
tears just started rolling down my eyes
because this is all I ever really really
wanted to experience and it happened and
it was really really crazy
[Music]